you had to put in a ton of work
what it what are you doing
oh another story to pick this up oh look
at that she's holding an award what is
that phallic-like award
right this is my people's choice award
did you win for uh rizzoli
i did yes congratulations how does that
how did that feel when you won an award
you wanna know that story that one was
terrible
so it was
i can't believe you're getting me to
tell all this i love it this is what
it's about
i know but like you know how private i
am and now you you got me
telling everything this is fun this is
what people want to hear they're going
to love you even more for like letting
go a little bit this is great
well you're going to love this so it was
the people's choice awards
and um it was the first day of my
mediation in my divorce so i was here in
charlotte and um
i started like getting you know all
these texts like congratulations
congratulations congratulations and you
know
my best friend
monica calls me and she's like
you won
and i'm like
oh what
what are you ever a few curse words in
there i was like no i do i'm on the
phone with my lawyer leave me alone
she calls me back and she's like listen
to me you won
you won your category and i'm like
i no i didn't what's her face won and
they and i was like no i don't have time
for this i gotta go i'm talking about
some serious crap here
you know hang up i mean and when i tell
you like my divorce was it was
devastating i mean i walked around with
my bible i mean it was you know
and so
she calls me back she goes
listen you dumbass
go to the website
and pull up your effing category and
look at your effing picture because
there is an effing banner that says
winner across your effing face
for people's choice awards
i didn't even get to go i wasn't even
there i didn't even get to do a speech i
didn't get to do anything oh my god but
that had to feel good during all that
that you're dealing with to have a
little acknowledgement to have a little
something like that that's nice
look at you
that's fantastic now if one of the kids
broke that how would you respond
well i mean i would kill them of course
and i would go to prison